翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Maki Sugimoto
今日は 実は 日本語で初めて
プレゼンテーションをするので
かなり緊張しています
みなさん よろしくお願いします
（拍手）
日本語を学ぶ時には
「あいうえお」から
勉強を始めますよね？
私は10年以上日本にいて
やっと「あいうえお」の
意味を発見しました
長い間日本にいて
たくさん学んだことを生かし
教育や経済成長を 母国の—
自分の国に繋げようと思って
今年の１月に戻りました
見ての通り私は ガイジンですね
そして ネパール人です
[2015年]４月25日
被害が大きかったカトマンズにも
私は２日前にいました
運が良いことに 私も私の家族も無事です
たまたま乗ったカトマンズで
たまたま乗ったタクシーの運転手が
山奥の山間の村に家族を
残してるという話を聞いて
僕も非常に心配になり
彼の縁で私は シンドゥパールチョク地区に
足を運ぶことになりました
現実は 車は入れず
山を歩いて２日間
4,100mのところに
彼の家族がいました
余震がまだまだ続いていまして
その村の80％の人達が被害に遭って
もちろん 家が壊れたり
あちこちに沢山の死がありました
私は早速 ロバを使って
本部チャウタラから
その山奥にある村に
ずっと 支援物資を届けました
２週間 物々交換生活をして
もちろん 毎日毎日 「死」を助けたり
瓦礫を片付けしたり
ネパールの政府からは 何も
支援を届けてくれませんでした
アメリカのヘリがやっと
支援物資を カトマンズから
持って飛びましたが
残念ながら ヘリが事故に遭いました
そして ネパール政府から
僕が助けている村は
危険地域として発表されました
海外支援も禁止として
全然来れませんでした
僕が助けない[と] という気持ちは
もちろんありましたが
現実はその村の人達は
読み書きはできないです
男たちはみんな街の中に
働きに出かけて行ったり
高齢者と子供しかいません
村を代表する人はいません
本当に毎日が ストレスの日でした
私も家族もネパールで
寄付を募ったり 支援をしたりとかは
してたんですけども
個人[では]限界があり
私はまた日本に戻って
寄付活動や支援者を
集めることになりました
私は日本の札幌にいますが
たくさんの友達がいます
本当に長い間 住んでいた町でもあって
私は北海道を第２の故郷と思っています
「ディリップ 本当に無事に帰ってきたね」
「いや 良かったね また会えた」
と言ってみなさん喜んでくれました
やっぱり みんなでチャリティイベントや
寄付活動も助けてくれたんです
でも 私は何か異変[を]感じました
まずは集中力っていうものが
全然ないんですね
毎日 毎日のことを
１時間後に全部忘れてしまうのです
そして夜は全然眠れないのです
とにかく 震災の夢
自分の息子が亡くなる夢
ばっかりみるのです
血圧もどんどん上がって
本当に辛かったです
病院の先生のところへ
足を運んだところ
私は最高レベルのPTSDだと言われました
本当にPTSDになってから
私はこんなに友達がいるのに
私はなぜネパールのことを もしかして
助けることができないんじゃないかな？
いってどんどんどんどん
ネガティブな方になりました
本当にPTSDだっていうことを
発見されたことは
精神的に本当に弱くなって
私はこのまま[で]は 難しいです
僕は みんなに迷惑を
かけてしまうんじゃないかと思って
自殺まで考えました
でも—
シンドゥパールチョク地区の人たち[を]
助けなければいけません
この人たちには もちろん緊急支援
というところは大事なんですけど
復興のビジョンを与える人がいません
もちろん 倒れた家も作らないといけない
写真で[は]見えない
たくさんの死の臭いもあります
病気も人間はやっぱりあちこちすぐトイレ
するようになったら病気もすぐ広がるんですね
私は思いました
やっぱり僕の今の現状と —
今ネパールに繋げたいビジョンはきっと
実際 震災を経験している方が持っています
私は仙台や神戸[へ]行って
皆さんに知恵を学ぼうと決めました
そして日本に来てから私はずっと
引きこもりと同じような生活をしていました
なるべく独りでいて
家からなかなか出なくて
友達にも会いたくないというのが
毎日でしたね
でも 現実はネパールに戻ってから
また4,100mの山に
登らないといけないんです
私は思いました
私はずっと３〜４ヶ月は
4,100mの山に登っているので
仙台から神戸を
歩いて行きたいと思いました
周りの友達 お世話になってる方
みなさん反対されました
でも 実際歩いてみると
東北大震災で助けられた沢山の人たち[が]
復興の知恵を教えてくれました
そして 毎日毎日40〜70km
毎日歩いていたんですけども
辛かったのです
でも これを乗り越えて行ければ
僕はもしかしてこの病気も
乗り越えて行けるかもしれません
仙台から神戸へ24日 歩いて917km
私は 自分のPTSDを治すことができました
TEDxコミュニティや初めて会う人
震災の経験者
私は沢山 学びました
大事なのは—
人が人を助けなければいけません
私たちの村 私たちの町 私たちの国
自分で復興しなければいけません
病気と震災 いつ起きるか分かりません
でも大事なのは
精神的な復興だと思いました
そして今 私は母国に戻って
この「あいうえお」から学んだことを
皆さんになるべく早めに
伝えたいという気持ちです
私が発見した「あいうえお」とは
「あ」は自分を愛して
人をも愛すること
「い」は自分の生命を大事にして
人の生命も大事にすること
「う」これ 一回流しますね
「え」は縁—私たちは人生の流れで
沢山の人と会って
その人が一人一人
自分をいつ助けてくれるか分かりません
一個一個の縁を大事にして行くこと
そして助けてくれた人たちには
きちんと恩返しをすること
こうやって自分を愛して人を愛して
自分の生命も大事にして
人の生命も大事にして
せっかくの縁を大事にして
恩返しすれば
「う」—運というものに
出会えるんですね
皆さん ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）